citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today I am going to do a movie reaction
because this reject is missing one movie
in a franchise a franchise where I've
seen all of them but one that is the
drifting of Tokyo Fast and Furious Tokyo
Drift first time watching today but is
the only one out of the Fast and Furious
films I have not seen of excluding the
one that's coming out in a few months I
was like it's about time I give this a
shot I don't know why I avoided it well
I think it's because it kind of got like
a bad rep when it first came out and
whatever I'll skip it and then uh as
time's gone on people it's gotten uh
more of a what's kind of more love I
think over I really don't know what the
conversation is surrounding it all I
know is I haven't seen this movie and I
was like I should just watch it I'm
gonna share my reaction with the reject
Nation so thank you all for being here
so drift on over to that like button if
you can I know you're capable of doing
it so please go ahead and do that
subscribe click the notification Bell we
got more videos coming up you know how
we do here at the reject patient is the
most I've said reject nation and intro
before also full-length retro watch
along where you sync up with your own
copy of Tokyo Drift available for our
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
so we call our patrons makes them feel
more exclusive I think it works yeah we
cover several things over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included I'm watching
this off hobo Max right now alrighty
guys let's see what this is all about
I gotta put myself in a mindset before
they were superheroes
foreign
because I saw him in the seventh movies
or seventh or sixth movie and I I feel
like I'm watching Like An Origin story
now
and it's Han's introduction
yo it's that guy from Home Improvement
nice ride does the job delivering pizzas
it's not the ride
is the rider nice hey
you talking to my girl it's a friendly
conversation man she was just a mind my
ride my rod stands for
trailer trash what about your daddy's
Viper oh he's got 500 horsepower and a
borley exhaust system it does 0-60 in
like 4.3 seconds you can read the
brochure
[Laughter]
[Music]
got it
oh hell no
why don't you nice boys let your car see
the talking I like yoga lady this car
goes for 80 grand what I do with a
broken ass piece of [__] like that
well if you're so confident
how about me winner gets
me oh my God this movie's so Progressive
I would hate having a girlfriend like
that though goddamn now that sucks
on instability of having a relationship
where she would just prostitute herself
uh with the bottom to back into baby
2006 baby
[Applause]
oh damn
dude you're not gonna win his girlfriend
is he allowed to do that
please keep your eyes forward I want you
to win I thought you loved me
[Laughter]
what is this [__] seriously toxic
relationship
oh dude
I guess I got a new date for prom oh my
God
dude
oh my God lay off the steroids man
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [__] I look painful
oh my God
for what the Fast and Furious franchise
has become this feels more grounded you
could actually feel the pain on this
[__] damn
laughs
can I get a copy of that you're going to
Tokyo son why does he go to Tokyo 100
guaranteed conviction where's my car I
crushed it you did what sit down you
understand you're done you know before
your 18th birthday now sit down this
guy's not 18. officer is it um
illegal to smoke in here
says no smoking right back there the one
sign in the whole interrogation room
your son's got two priors for reckless
driving willful destruction of property
they're definitely going to get them off
the streets
well there's just
Tokyo so where are we moving this time
we are not moving any
[Music]
that was a good transition although for
a moment I did think he was in a
hospital I guess he's going to Tokyo
whatever gets us there
'd be great to visit here look how
beautiful it is
sure
I thought you're going to be here on the
seventh
ah okay this makes more sense
oh what is he doing at the like an
American Psycho situation
you know she had no other choice I mean
it was either this or juvie hall I mean
you just can't keep moving away every
time you get into trouble
theme you go to school you come back
here right after
and I don't want to see or hear about
you anywhere near a car especially no
drifting
God this looks like every room John has
ever occupied or taken over
[Music]
be careful Sean
you're gonna have to be racing her on
the streets later
you'll fit her right in
only the non-asian girl is checking you
out man
foreign
[Music]
Japanese food is like um
don't ask don't tell
names
you ain't have a laptop I'll hook you up
half price I ain't got no cash man well
what about a cell phone
I'm probably not going to be here long
enough to remember your name
ain't gonna need some new shoes to book
town with me
[Laughter]
you selling Sparkle stand well that's
mine right there
when I even pay retail for it you paid
retail my ride's One of a Kind Show me
holy [__] is that how it works in Japan
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
oh my God I love this it's just a like a
pure Asian Fast and Furious movie where
you follow characters who are not Asians
[Music]
there's one thing consistent in all
these movies it's the world
of illegal street racing and the kind of
supermodels that occupy it
oh [__] how did I fail to predict that
she herself was into all this so where
are you from anyway
here
where'd you come from
does it really matter where I'm from
oh that's a villain look right there
who's a tourist on
gaiji we were just talking that word you
call me Gaijin or something
what does that mean exactly something
complimentary
I see Yakuza you know who I am boy
you like the Justin Timberlake of Japan
good luck Timber Lake
[Music]
whoa
you're the one that's lucky is that what
it is and let's race
oh my God Sean's gonna destroy Japan
easy to sound cocky when you got no ride
take mine
what the hell can he drive
can he drive
you know what DK stands for Donkey Kong
drift King drift King what do you mean
drill
oh this is fun
it's fun learning all these things about
Han when I'm aware of
the crazy Adventures he's been on prior
to this movie story and how none of that
was canon in the writer's praise
go
let's see what's going on
yikes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh DK
[Laughter]
oh my God this is so embarrassing
[Applause]
how is he not fat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
God damn this is so bad
[Applause]
holy [__] no way what
do people do this
[Applause]
Sean give up
I could be with a hot girl
oh he's got like five bottles there if
you're gonna live under my roof you're
gonna go buy my rules or get out
understand
just say yeah and do what you got to do
man I'll get you your money
why are you talking like you have a
choice
there's a guy in there with a paw that
owes me some money what's up Paul
like a dog a bear a monkey why we need a
job hold on
[Music]
so he just has to make a guess as to who
it is
that would be it on said oh Kenny
oh we just gotta put his clothes back on
[Music]
let's go he is cool man I'm already like
I get why you brought this guy back
might call you once a week or once an
hour I call you show only if you teach
me how to drift stay in a negotiation I
wasn't negotiator
he learned how to drift from Han not
Twinkie
I thought I'd stop by and ask your
boyfriend for some drifting lessons
trust me you don't want to be a part of
this world that's good enough for you
you don't know anything about me I know
you're very attractive you're an army
Brad he moved around a lot
Mom and Daddy was never home so you
walked around pissed off all the time
now you found your family with these
drift nuts drift nuts
zero for one cowboy
can't you go find a nice Japanese girl
like the rest of the white guys around
here
Fair Point well I need them
keeps Uncle kamada from poking around
too much
what do you mean well his uncle gets a
piece of the action from everyone on
this turf
run this Turf 50 of something is better
than 100 of nothing that's not true it's
like YouTube monetization It's the point
of a race see if I'm better than other
guys just proves you're faster that's
all that would erase it would have to be
for some important something important
[Music]
show them what you got NOS
sure we might as well race why not
[Music]
what the police cars the only Factory
tune you can do better than 180k they
can't catch you so they don't even try
holy [__] that can't be true I know
there are countries without speed limits
let's go
[Music]
foreign
this movie I really wish the Fast and
Furious movie stayed in this world more
[Music]
it's like he got over Giselle fast
oh my God this is heaven the red Evo's
yours
what do you mean well yeah what what you
think I'm gonna let you roll in a
Hyundai
thank you
oh holy [__]
holy [__]
[Applause]
that does look really really hard where
did you find this guy
[Applause]
I really do like how this is a genuine
obstacle for him it's got potential
foreign
Maybe
we'll see are we talking about the car
are we talking about you Sean you're
showing the Japanese have a saying
the nail that sticks out gets hammered I
don't know when to apply that
you're gonna be late
and these high school kids get real
taken advantage of
thank you
hey look man I don't do refunds all
right try not to break this
how iPods that it's an iPad I forgot
about iPods the hell is wrong with you
huh not everybody's going exchanges
around here
we went to you Sean because we thought
you would know how to handle the
situation better than anyone else not
easy saving the day is it I mean you can
give me some pointers sometime you're
doing all right thanks I love their
scenes they're always the same tone so
how'd you end up over here anyway well
you know those old westerns the Cowboys
make a run for the Border
is my Mexico
I gotta go back and watch fast six now
36. it's a trust and character I need
around me who you choose to be around
you
that you know who you are that is true
one car in exchange for knowing what a
man's made of that's a price I can live
with
you're an all right guy hon so if you
don't drift to win what do you drill for
[Music]
the latest
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a whole history to the drifting
huh watch it not too early now
[Applause]
damn he's getting it of course he's
gonna get it but damn it's cool he's
getting it
[Music]
[Applause]
damn oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
I do love the a practical stunt driving
that this movie will show me obviously
some stuff will CGI but like [__] like
this man it's awesome
[Applause]
hello
oh no way he won
[Applause]
[Music]
uh oh
guys you're doing business
trip tonight
this movie's taught me one thing being
good at racing gets you the girl my
parents split up when I was three me and
Mom moved around a lot it was all
because of me kind of made myself an
outsider you know
Southern but I realize now outside our
Insider doesn't really matter all that
matters knowing what you really want
yeah might as well go after her get
yourself killed man
oh my God look at them they're all drift
compatible
[Music]
[Laughter]
today I got my license today I got my
first speeding ticket Born to Race day
after that I won my first race
key of My Three Links I don't know what
three lengths means
[Music]
what the hell is going on
oh this is getting personal now okay
grab a chair we're about to roast some
marshmallows
yo come on man
yep should not be hanging out with the
man's girl stay away from her or the
only thing you'll be driving is a
wheelchair
find yourself a new driver
oh I was picking on him
I'm all right we're gonna just play with
fire he soak the matches in gasoline
Sean you really are a screw-up you know
that man
don't smile at him
[Music]
it's over
oh this is
I am a Gaijin I should have called this
guy change DK
he used to be a good nephew of a
gangster you say I've changed
but we're not so different you and I
We're Not So Different you and I they
say your mom was the best trick in all
of Google back in the day oh that's
messed up differences I know who I am
and what up at all
I am the female character of this movie
hey
such as soap up with them but I enjoy it
I do I'd be lying if I said I didn't
I enjoy
them two together
were you
um
oh I know
a nail and a wood thing
foreign
it's still about family
hey brother
whoa keep your side deals for me it's
been in the Boy Scouts it's what we do
oh don't don't uh you're just gonna make
it worse what are you doing here
nicely done
oh my God you gotta Drift Away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God drifting out of necessity
wow that looks really scary to do
damn
holy [__] that is scary that is cool
wow
It's gotta be a mix of some CGI cars in
traffic right
wow what's up look at that
foreign
drive through the crowd of people they
live their lives in fear
[Applause]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so much drifting
[Applause]
oh it's messed up man
that's Jason Statham
foreign
[Music]
wow I always thought Furious 7 did a
weird job on justifying how he's still
alive and now I especially think it's
weird but screw it he's back
[Music]
I wouldn't do that if I were you
okay
I'll go with you
I drift because that would be awesome
it's about family
putting you on a plane tonight I did
this I can't run away remember your
advice at the beginning of this move it
pops I'm your father I'm responsible for
your well-being
and I'm responsible for my mess
oh my God
I gotta do this
can you understand that yes yes he can
the way of the Japanese people in Tokyo
there's a saying about nails and wood
and and
don't step on them something I think Han
would have wanted you to have
giselle's body you're gonna need if
you're gonna make it out of Commodus
Place alive
you have five hundred dollars in here
man
they can't drink and then we're called
Gringo in Japan
here we go
it's not just Sean oh my God she looks
so so ugly I've never seen a more
horrendous looking human being
damn you picked you put Japanese well he
drifted into that language
I'm here to offer you a peaceful
solution
how do you prevent the accomplish that
drift erase yes it's the cops to call
the cause
you could build your own
oh nice symbolic
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
yes it's about family
[Applause]
DK picked his role for a reason he's the
only one ever make it to the bottom
not today it's about family or some
shoes
now that's sex appeal
look and fly
wow damn they're doing this at night
oh my God the super ugly girls worked
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
damn
it's your mountain now Sean
they put those cars close together it is
scary
come on
dude he is acing this
it's going too well it's going too well
oh man
it's nice to return to a time in this
franchise when there was a comprehension
of physics to a certain degree
just turn the lights off
oh my goodness
that was a great shot
[Applause]
whoa
[Laughter]
dude
I mean he must win
yeah
oh
[Applause]
you race for me now
[Music]
can someone translate for me what he
said
foreign
racing
[Music]
this is like a Fast and Furious Tokyo
Drift song at the theme song
check this out man
God don't like that new look she's so
ugly
okay said harm was family
so I heard about that I totally forgot
all it took was that magic word to
remind me
this is all I heard about this out he
had a cameo in it
there he is
wow he he was younger at one point I
didn't know he was into American Muscle
it was when he was rolling with me you
know this ain't no 10 second race
I got nothing but time that's true he's
got like 20 more of these movies now
you ready kid
[Applause]
yeah I gotta admit though man Vin Diesel
does have that star Charisma
drift with that car
holy crap really
they had to put that out there
what was going on at the time of this
movie's release
we need disclaimers like that for all
the Fast and Furious movies now don't be
jumping out of airplanes without
parachutes all right well there's no
need for like a big in-depth review on
this you know I think you like the
reaction kind of speaks for itself I had
a I had a lot of fun with that movie
that was that was a lot of fun it's it's
interesting coming from this experience
on it because I would I'd like to be in
the position where I was wise enough to
go against the grain
and go and watch this movie in the
theaters in 2006 like a good man but
instead I listen to naysayers
and I didn't really care for too fast
actually I think I like Too Fast Too
Furious I only saw the one time
bottom line I missed out on it but to go
Nine Movies in Miss the what is
essentially in a lot of ways it's it's
more Canon than it's it's actually very
much Canon to The Fast and Furious
timeline but in a lot of ways
you know Omni media said it best because
I told him I was going to be watching
this movie and he said it's kind of the
uh Halloween Season of the Witch of the
franchise at the time it came out where
you know if you were like well Vin
Diesel was none and if Paul Walker's on
it what's the point in actually watching
it
but I see why people like it I mean it's
it's a good fast I missed kind of these
days of Fast and Furious I think I like
it more
than 2 Fast Too Furious even though I
don't really remember it I think I like
it more than 2 Fast 2 Furious and and I
I enjoyed it more than even like F9 uh
definitely more than Fast and Furious
did not like that movie that much
wasn't until like Fast Five you know I I
if I were to rank this I'd probably go
like Fast Five furious six fast seven
Fast and Furious Tokyo The Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift I'm sort of winging
it I don't really know I've only seen
most of them just one time so I don't I
don't really know if my ranking would be
needless to say I was pleasantly
surprised by this I was worried it was
gonna be boring
then again it was Justin Lynn's first
film then he was the main director the
Christopher McCrory if you will of this
franchise for quite some time even
supposed to have directed the last one
but then [__] went a little bit Haywire
there
and I I see I can get why at the time it
would not be well received uh you know
because
especially with what Fast and Furious is
about family certain set of characters
and stuff but I really enjoyed this one
uh I like the Fish Out of Water Element
to it I thought you know going back to
the the time where it was
obviously there's gonna be a lot of CGI
in there but not that CGI Reliant like
for the most part it's grounded in a
sense of reality and to get a lot of the
street racing and the drifting like it
was actually really cool and as sappy
and melodramatic as some of these
moments can certainly be where the
cheese is really amped up to a degree
where it's you know the movie itself
seems to lack self-awareness in certain
scenes it's not like overly cheesy it's
not overdoing it but it just hits it
right enough to be like this is pretty
corny this is pretty cheesy but because
I'm a viewer who is so well down the
pipeline now uh where I'm all the way
into F9 that this to me is is nothing
you know it's nothing like it is so far
from what this franchise becomes that to
me I'm like wow this is like a grounded
approach this is realistic it would be
kind of jarring if the Fast and Furious
franchise moved back to something like
this because and it's nice to be
reminded of of a time like that because
I saw the first one uh quite a few times
and then the other ones I've only seen
once so yeah to be seeing
to be seeing um to be seeing this it was
it's cool going in the context of
knowing like my real introduction to Han
was Fast Five and Furious 6 and F9 and
and then having the context of Shaw and
then you're like piecing it together
like they clearly did not they clearly
like made this [__] up as they went
along like it's not it's not like some
of the best anime you'll watch uh like
I've been reading Attack on Titan manga
and I'm like damn you know uh because
the new Season's coming out for Attack
on Titan I don't know when uh but it's
I've been seeing on Twitter I'm like
[__] I gotta like get a refresher and I
thought instead of re-watching the show
read the Manga and then to to go back to
the very beginning it's crazy if you're
uh and like I feel like shows like
Naruto do this like some of the best
animes just do this where
you can go so far down the rabbit hole
and it's mapped out better than any
Cinematic Universe you get in America
better than MCU or DC Universe you know
any any Cinematic Universe
like anime does that so well and there
are parts of this that remind me of
anime that might sound racist because
they're in Japan but it does there are
parts of it that remind me of an anime
uh this is like the the type of
tone the bravado and the height that
just enough heightenedness of it there
there were there were qualities about it
like I wouldn't even call the later ones
like an anime those are something other
some other kind of cartoon uh the this
this had that that nice little punch it
was like an american guy trying to make
an anime directed by an Asian director
who I don't know if his Asian American
or actually Asian Asian I don't know
where Justin Lynn is from so my point
with that is when you get to this moment
with Han where he does die uh it's not
like the best anime where you go wow
they've been napping this out since the
beginning and we're like 10 seasons into
this show but it's so obvious they
really had that mapped out since the
beginning how they get this far
it's really what this did for my
experience was go yeah they were they've
definitely been making [__] up as they
went along
like let's have Shaw be the guy who
crashed the car in there let's uh looks
like they didn't come up with Shaw then
let's let's let's have him know what
happened I don't remember how he
survived but the explanation was like he
just wasn't in the car and then like he
witnessed it happened he was standing
with Kurt Russell or some [__] right
it's I barely remember what occurred
but yeah it's clearly silly but seeing
like the real introduction the way how a
lot of people got to experience Han
because I know this movie definitely got
more viewership than less viewership
than Fast Five but the way a lot of
people got to experience on through this
film
was cool because it is fun playing the
game of knowing the the Canon they made
up after uh when they did like Fast Five
and furious six
but you know it is he is like a
different kind of character here and he
is more of like a gangster and
but he's like the cool gangster the one
you feel like you can still be like
vulnerable around and still be friends
with you know he's a really cool guy and
he and to me he was he it wasn't just
because I'm familiar with him I
undoubtedly would walk and I suspect
that's probably why they brought him
back and wanted to find a way to bring
him back is because he is the best
character in this film
and yeah you know when I would see like
a clip or two from it's a very different
kind of discussion for me because I've
of course been like somewhat familiar
with this movie uh just through via you
know and the rest of the movies and the
franchise and [__] is uh with uh with
Sean i i a big part of it was I just did
like even when I would see him in the
other films
it's like ah there's nothing about this
is making me want to go check out Tokyo
Drift especially like when you seem like
Furious 7 and [__]
like they're kind of fun and whatever
but nothing that was like I wanted I
need to go see that third film
they're presented differently here
you know I'm not
I'm not I wouldn't say I'm I'm in love
with these characters
but I really enjoyed them I I that would
be it would be it would be a straight up
lie if I said I did not enjoy them I I
did enjoy them uh I enjoyed Sean he was
a character sometimes I'd see a clip or
two and like there's no way I'm gonna
like this [__] but I did they had a very
clear character Arc and they really laid
it out for you uh but I and his he's got
a he's real real southern guy
um you hear his parents and you're like
he sounds so much more Southern than his
parents
but I I as a character I was I wasn't
dear to him I thought it would be he
doesn't like possess the
star power charisma
because that is the thing that happens
at the very end of this film you know
when you do see Vin Diesel and him
you're like yeah there's something about
Vin Diesel that is not like the greatest
freaking actor in the world but but he
does he does have whatever they call it
to be he's got he's got that it factor
that even if you really he's not a
really great actor but he's still got
something about him that makes him a
leading man and and and uh and you see
that that Charisma there you're like
yeah yeah he doesn't have that kind of
power but I was surprised walking into
this to be enjoying the Ensemble I'd
like Takashi I thought he was a
interesting villain who had the
complexity of you know bde energy and uh
wanting to
you know be tough and [__] but he's also
so submissive to his uncle there's ah
and it still Falls in tune with the the
family joke about this whole franchise
because this is still dealing with
families you know it's a father and son
story and growing up and there and and
then with Takashi his uncle his is like
his father and
you know he becomes so submissive to him
and it's about pleasing him and whereas
you got one path of the of our Caucasian
character uh finding his own way and the
other one just trying to be
obedient and a loyal servant to his
uncle
but that's also dealing with like Yakuza
and different cultures and stuff or
whatever it's just a lot of fun drama
who's the girl let me let me pull up the
imdiba over here
it is played by Natalie Kelly
Peruvian and Argentine
yeah
yeah they had weird chemistry
it was
it was really flat chemistry but it's it
had that it had that weird charm to me
though I went anywhere I'm not I don't
feel like they got some Dynamite
chemistry or some [__] and and the way
their scenes played out it was always
the same kind of pitch and the same kind
of note in the same kind of flirtatious
way of talking to each other and it
really felt like the script forced
emotional connection instead of truly
finding it
I don't care like that's one of the
things with this you're like yeah this
is passable enough for me to like yeah
let's move it along find it interesting
and they had other character moments
that I thought were
they would at least make the attempt to
elevate it like with Takashi and her
having that Showdown was right up in her
face there's a lot of right up in your
face action scenes uh dialogue scenes
here
a lot of intimidation really close to
each other
but you know get into it and and bow wow
I thought was entertaining man is
Twinkie I thought he was really
entertaining and then being familiar
with Leonardo Nam and like other works
he's done and then to see him here if I
did not know his other works I would
believe this is the kind of guy Leonardo
Nam always plays do you guys know who
Leonardo Nam is
if you don't that speaks volumes for his
portrayal here as character whose name I
don't remember he was number two to uh
Takashi in this film
and you know getting like the the
Japanese culture and really letting it
like the the it was like
in in the in a franchise that has
evolved into a globe trotting Adventure
it was cool to get an installment that
just focused on one part of culture like
there are some moments that yeah they
read a tad sappy
like when they're all drifting together
up the mountain at night and it's kind
of supposed to be romantic but they're
talking about watching them drift and
there's there's a but there's like this
weird Community Vibe about it but then
you get like the cool different angles
of it of of an American dude getting to
experience how laws in the underground
World works over here and the Aesthetics
to it it was nice to just have it zero
in on Tokyo and really get to experience
that really get to feel that
it a part of me made me go I wish there
was a an ALT Universe where we got to
really
find a way to make this work for the for
the for the Ensemble here or the
characters here and and and let their
stories actually continue instead of
just being funny cameos that now appear
it would have been neat because there
was something here there is something
pretty special and
and I gotta say like the the funny part
about it is the The Fast and Furious
franchise from after Fast Five were
really embraced a new type of
a new type of extremity and it's just
about constantly upping that angle and
then leaning into some of its very
overtly cheesy qualities you know like
the family angle and then you get some
new big bad guy in there who also is
what I love about the bad guys and the
new ones is how they they'll they're
they're also obsessed with cars I was
watching the the last Fast and Furious
trailer and Jason Momoa was racing him
and I'm like why are these bad guys
they're all the bad guys are in the cars
too it's just it's always been some
Family Feud and they're also into cars
it's good it's good it works it always
works out that way the cards are always
there
so yeah it's it is just pure silliness
and I thought there were actually some
scenes here where the drama was hitting
just enough like I was never really
strongly moved emotionally but it was
enough to keep me engaged
and there was this sense of groundedness
with the racing and the action where I
would you know like Fast and Furious now
it's more like whoa cool that's crazy
and then here it's a different kind of
crazy for example I remember watching
the the trailer for the last one there's
this one little bike stunt for this I
think it's like a female bike rider she
like goes over like this little curb or
wall I don't know what it was but she
went over it's really brief moment in
the trailer and it's not this crazy
explosive stunt but it it looks so real
and it felt so tangible
and this provided so much of that for me
despite the few not the few but you know
they would have to blend certain moments
with CGI there was a lot of this where
you could it was tangible it you could
feel the stunt drivers behind it and
I know that the later movies blend at
but that's the thing is it's so it's so
Blended in that you don't even really
get to appreciate it because there's so
much other crazies going on that it
doesn't even really register a lot of
the time that man look at those stunt
performers and and I like seeing the
magic of that in this film where I am
very much aware that yeah these are real
like they have to do a [__]
disclaimer at the end of this movie of
like don't do this [__] because they had
real people doing it and that to me was
one of the most invigorating parts of it
was getting back to that grounded sense
and it's something that I don't know if
the franchise could ever go back there
so it was weird to go to a film to the
third installment in this franchise like
let me do some quick math here minus 13
for 17 years ago to go 17 years ago and
see
this where if it had come out today I'd
be like wow this is the this is a neat
direction for the franchise to go down
well look actually it's super old and
and uh it and it doesn't feel it didn't
feel repetitive so
as much as I don't have like an
Nostalgia for Tokyo drugs this is the
first time I'm watching it I did find
myself going oh it's a bummer that the
franchise seemed to lose sight of
this kind of quality and it's sad to me
that the love for this film came around
later
instead of
when it first did come out
I mean don't get me wrong I really do
enjoy the other films like they're
they're a blast not a big fan of F9 but
the other films I I really do enjoy so
except for the fourth okay the fourth
one I don't like but five six seven and
then pretty much most debate I really
enjoy
F9 was a little bit of a it was a pretty
hard experience for me that was really
up and down but I'm looking forward to
fast sex
uh
yeah now this was I I don't know just
kind of it's like a
what is the phrase I'm looking for
um a bottle what is that [__] phrase
excuse me guys bottle in time a capsule
in time a capsule of a certain time you
know it's like when they talk about
movies that were Song of the South
the the phrase will come to me when the
camera's not rolling when they talk
about like movies that were like yeah
but he captured a moment in time of
American History Cinema and stuff when
they're when they defend by a racist
villain should exists or something and
that's what this cap it's like a time
capsule of what this franchise once was
but I thought I think when you go back
to him like actually this worked this
worked I thought it was good I I thought
it was good
and um I was surprised by how much I
enjoyed it I thought I would be bored I
was nervous I put this off for a while
but I wasn't bored I really enjoyed it
and I'm glad I got to experience it with
you all so
anyway
my conversation is is just off the rails
it's just it's just off off-roading
drifting in all kinds of directions
like how this franchise has become but
hey I had fun I hope you guys did too
thank you so much for being here
sure support leave a like subscribe and
I will talk with you all soon
[Music]